the Democratic Republic of Congo is
facing its deadly deadliest Ebola
outbreak ever the World Health
Organization is warning the disease
could spread to other African countries
making matters worse the DRC's
quarter-century old civil war is
disrupting efforts to treat and contain
the outbreak Debora patta is there this
morning violence and mistrust are
seriously hampering efforts to contain
this outbreak Ebola treatment centers
like this one are often attacked by
militia groups and people are either too
scared or too suspicious to seek medical
help
Ebola is not the only enemy here nine
people were killed in this village by an
armed militia group their soldiers took
the victims to be tested for the disease
it's standard practice Ebola is at its
most contagious immediately after death
we don't understand what the sea bola is
this man says we can bury the bodies of
our people ourselves a 3,000 strong UN
peacekeeping force is deployed in this
area to protect villagers from the over
30 armed militia groups that terrorized
the community you can see how thick and
dense the jungle is here this is where
the militia hide are making it very
difficult to track them and now war
weary residents have to face down
another invisible enemy Ebola community
outreach programs have been launched to
educate people about the virus but
mistrust runs deep USAID's dr. bill
clemmer has worked in the DRC for over
two decades I've never been at a context
where people throw rocks at our
vaccination team where they block roads
where they loot and pillage our health
care facilities Beni has all the tools
to fight Ebola at its disposal but it's
all useless if the sick and the dying
have hide in their homes refusing
medical treatment only 50% of people
infected with Ebola are seeking medical
treatment and they're between 10 to 20
new cases every day the longer this
outbreak rages on the
by the risk of it spreading regionally
and even globally for CBS this morning
Debora patta bene Democratic Republic of
Congo